what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I've been thinking about this
for the last few weeks or so really last
like you know we gonna have something
like that ever since Bart Allen returned
in DC rebirth with super Sons of
tomorrow and the more I thought about it
the more I kind of came to this
realization that with Bart Allen being
so involved in like you know the flash
landscape probably terminal-velocity
different things like that and even
though the role that he played in the
new 52 I'll be a kind of a
reinvigoration of its character that a
lot of fans didn't really care for and
if I'm at an expo in the middle of super
Sons is not really enough to offer a
real explanation on Bart Allen so we're
gonna do a character discussion on him
which I kind of need to do because it's
been a while since we've done one now
those of you guys who are really really
familiar with Bart Allen you're gonna go
crazy and you're gonna be like what and
you're gonna think I'm nuts when I tell
you that Bart Allen's introduction into
DC Comics is really part and parcel to
the death of Superman so for those of
you guys who were new when it comes to
comic books you have what are called
paradigm shifts which is to say the
introduction or set of events that
basically changes the entirety of the
industry itself now a lot of people will
say that like Action Comics number one
really changed the comic book industry
but the industry didn't exist Action
Comics number one Detective Comics
number 27 Wiz colics number two the
introductions basically if Superman
Batman and Captain Marvel the
introduction of those characters really
set the groundwork for what would become
the comic book industry but for me the
first major paradigm shift in comic
books came in 1956 with the introduction
of Barry Allen and the reason why was
because of the fact that following the
end of world war ii comics just weren't
that popular anymore at least not
superheroes instead people wanted to
reprieve from all the political stuff
and all the fighting and different
things like that and they wanted to
focus on you know crazy far-out sci-fi
adventures and so for the most part
science fiction was the name of the game
the introduction of Barry Allen took
these sci-fi themes and blended them
with superheroes and it worked perfectly
because following the introduction of
Barry Allen suddenly the stage was set
for this whole new era of comic books
now that ran up until what I would
consider to be the next paradigm shift
which was the night when Stacey died
which of course was basically this idea
that a superhero could fail disastrously
by virtue of his own inaction or his own
recklessness of course you know 1985's
crisis on Infinite Earths you know the
first major reboot by DC the Dark Knight
Returns all these things really focus on
these sort of shifts that help to evolve
the comic-book landscape but one of the
most important things to ever happen in
the comic book industry was the death of
Superman and max landis did a really
really
old video about this you know the death
the return of Superman and one of the
things that he talked about was that
Superman dying and then coming back some
six months to a year later basically
killed death and comic books Superman
was the most popular superhero of
autonomy he's you know more recognizable
than like religious figures and so the
idea is if the most popular superhero in
the world can die and come back did why
can't anybody else die and come back and
so suddenly you sort of seen this
massive explosion of superheroes who had
previously been killed off like Colossus
you know who died during the end of the
whole legacy virus thing that stretched
on for you know seven or eight years who
basically came back under Joss Whedon's
run in 2004 you saw all these things
going on with regard to these characters
being killed and returning but the
reason why I say the introduction of
bart allen is part and parcel to the
death of superman is because while
superman dying and then returning
effectively killed the sales of action
comics what it did do is it just
skyrocketed the sales of Superman at the
time that people thought he was going to
be gone forever
when the flash comics were originally
written after the events of crisis on
Infinite Earths which is to say when
Mike Baron and Bill Loeb took up the
flash title for the most part for the
first however many issues at the
publication lasted under their belt it
was really by and large this sort of
series of stories where Wally West was
quote-unquote living under the shadow of
Barry Allen and it was pretty
interesting because it sort of painted
his picture of a lot of people who felt
like they'd been overshadowed by
relatives different things like that but
in truth the line of stories began to
wear thin and so what ended up happening
is maybe some seven years after crisis
on Infinite Earths was written writer
Mark Waid took over the flash title with
issue number 62 and wrote this story
called born to run now Born to Run was
really just kind of a retelling of Wally
West's origin it was basically a way for
a Markway to come along in sync this is
a fresh starting off point not really a
reboot so much is just a place for you
to jump in and pick up everything that's
going on and over the course of Mark
Waid run when it came to Wally West and
we talked about this you know and Wally
West explained which you'll find down in
the description it was really kind of
moving away from the aw he's living
under the shadow of Barry and instead
focusing on growing the character of
Wally was saying look yeah he's under
the shadow of Barry Allen but people
don't want to see stories where he
constantly struggles with that they want
to see what he can do on his own and so
Mark Waid was really kind of considered
to be like these standard with the flash
writer I mean you go back and you look
at all the runs of the flash that have
ever existed in the history of DC Comics
and most anybody will tell you Mark
Wade's run is at the very top it was
ground
in a lot of different ways and one of
these was because of the introduction of
bart allen now again with this whole
idea really feeding into the death of
Superman where DC looked around and saw
the sales of Action Comics it's kind of
floundered following Superman's return
because people felt tricked they felt
duped DC really kind of learned not to
pull the same gag twice and so instead
of actually killing off Wally West
what DC did is they kind of offered this
red herring that maybe Wally West will
die and initially it all really started
off with like zero hour crisis and time
and there was this really good
interviewer Mark Waid did where he
talked about this idea that was zero
hour crisis in time DC had a lot of
continuity issues that were left over
after crisis on Infinite Earths for
example most characters after the first
crisis basically got reboot stories
within a year I mean you didn't really
see or hear from them until they
received a reboot like me oh if Superman
was a really good example you got John
Byrne's Superman the Man of Steel which
basically gave you this whole new origin
for Superman's character in the
post-crisis landscape but he had
characters like Hawkman for example who
didn't get a new origin until three
years after crisis on Infinite Earths
happened yet he was still around
and so people kind of asked the question
well then what's his new origin like how
do we reconcile this character who's
basically hails from a universe that's
not supposed to exist anymore and so
because there were all these different
continuity issues DC believed they could
basically clear it up using zero our
crisis and Todd and so during the zero
hour crisis and x story
wally west was effectively thrown into
the timestream and ended up seeing a
future where his love interest at the
time glenda park was basically going to
die and he didn't know if there was a
way to basically save her and so this
combined with the introduction of other
things like the Speed Force and so on
and so forth effectively set the stage
for the idea that Wally waswas going to
try to find a way to save Linda Park and
in the process effectively die at the
same time and probably some 30 issues
after his inaugural run with issue
number 92 back in 1994 Mark Waid sat
down and came to this realization that
if they were going to basically lead the
entire reader base of the flash comics
to believe that wally west was going to
die then it had to be convincing and
again this is actually covered in a
couple interviews that he's done
tomorrow's publishing secret
organization comicbook.com different
things like that you can usually look up
Mark Waid interviews and find them for
the most part but the idea was they had
to make it convincing the issue they
face is that Wally West as a character
was predicated on being Kid Flash which
is to say that as a
boy he basically received his powers as
the flash in the exact same way very
allen didn't so parkway catalog Donna
said if we've been going through all
these steps for you know some 30 issues
whatever it is to basically move Wally
west away from the quote-unquote Barry
Allen archetype then why would it make
sense to introduce a new kid flash that
follows in the exact same steps as Wally
West and so what Mark Waid ended up
doing is in flash volume 2 issue number
92 he introduced the character at Bart
Allen now Mort Allen's introduction
actually came in a couple different ways
and it was really hot on the heels of
the return of characters like max
mercury for example who way back in the
Silver Age was Quicksilver but when he
was reintroduced by Mark Waid he was
basically just called max mercury he was
hot off the heels of those characters
basically popping back up the idea that
they were being reintroduced and kind of
consolidating all the speedster
information which we'll talk about here
in a minute but what ended up happening
here is there was basically a point
whereby iris West really you know I
guess I are silent if that's what you
want to call it was it a 30th century
and of course the reason for that is
really outside of the scope of this
video but the fact remains that barn ala
was introduced as the grandson of Barry
Allen living in the 30th century the
problem with his character with regards
to the DC landscape is that he was
essentially stuck in hyper acceleration
and what this meant was that his body
was physically aging faster than his
mind as a result of the Speed Force and
so what ended up happening is iris had
this idea to send him back to the 20th
century and see if there would be a way
for Wally West who effectively fix him
so there was really nobody alive at that
point in time who was as adept with
regards to you like this Speed Force and
how all that worked as wally west was in
the 20th century and so of course the
cool thing about this was that with the
introduction of bart allen and
effectively being this new quote-unquote
kid flash mark waid had to find a way to
basically say okay if he's gonna be kid
flash we can't kill him off in six
months because he's aged so fast we got
to find a way to basically you know slow
his aging down and so essentially it was
a story whereby Wally West had raced
bart allen around the world and then
essentially just kind of set his speed
powers back to rights meaning that he
would age at a normal rate and so what
ended up happening is Mark Waid actually
crafted this really really really cool
set of events leading up the terminal
velocity in the flash issue number 100
and over the course of these eight
issues it was essentially established
that Wally West did not know how to
handle bart allen bart allen was
reckless that he was headstrong he
basically leaped before he looked and it
was a great way to grab the element of
the 1990s teenager you know not to Don
his young kid and
in there because a lot of kids love the
idea of being impulsive and really
living in the moment it's just kind of a
byproduct of being young and so because
bart allen was introduced as essentially
this sort of encounter book stand-in for
the nature of what it meant to be a
teenager in the 1990s and really a
teenager in any era readers immediately
latched on to him and in order to
basically keep the character of bart
allen going absent the involvement of
wally west what ended up happening here
is Mark Waid took the character of Bart
and made him a protege of Max mercury
now again this really ran up until issue
number 100 and the reason why was
because of the fact that while Bart
Allen was kind of a protege of Max
mercury following that terminal velocity
was essentially designed to be this sort
of you know this is where it all ends
this is where Wally West dies and of
course it gave us like the whole origin
of the Speed Force you know when all
those different kinds of things now the
reason why that matters is because
historically speaking when it came to
the various speedsters in DC Comics
there really was no unifying factor in
terms of how they got their powers the
only unifying factor was that they could
all move really fast now different
people use their speed in different ways
but you look at someone like Johnny
chambers and Jesse chambers and it was a
calculation that granted them their
powers you look at Wally West he got his
powers the exact same way as Barry Allen
Barry Allen got his powers by being
dousing chemicals and struck by
lightning at the same time and so what
ended up happening is Mark Waid sat down
and crafted the Speed Force as
effectively this other dimensional
source of energy from which all
speedsters gained their power and so
what he'd done is he looked at the
characters of Jay Garrick all the way
back in the Golden Age he looked at the
characters of Jesse chambers of Johnny
chambers he looked at max mercury he
looked at impulse Wally West very now
the whole nine yards and woody
essentially said is the means by which
they gain their powers is still intact
Wally West was struck by lightning in
dust and chemicals very on the exact
same thing Johnny and Jesse chambers use
a mathematical proof in order to access
their powers but what all these
characters ended up doing was
effectively tapping into the Speed Force
they just didn't know it at the time and
this really came by way of an expose for
max mercury in the sense that in terms
of the in DC universe chronology max
mercury was the first person that's
happened to the speedforce meaning he
was basically the first person to
realize it was there and it realized
that was the source of their energy now
because the fact that max mercury had
been brought back effectively became the
sort of Zen master of the speedsters
where as Jay Garrick was his old man
flash the whole idea behind this was
that he was put in the perfect position
to be a mentor
for bart allen and so fans could quite
literally read bart allen stories and
basically learn about him as a character
as they read the stories learn about how
the Speed Force works kind of have this
sort of coming to age series at the same
time and within a year after making his
debut were really a few years after
making his debut because of the fact
that impulse was such a wildly popular
character among young readers in the
sense that kids in the mid 90s basically
got their own version of the Kid Flash
he of course it got his own solo series
and this ran for quite a little bit I
mean it ran between 90 95 all the way up
to 2002 really running all the way up to
issue number 89 but again a Mark Waid
was like the main contributor for it and
he had people who would be stand-in
writers you know like Brian Augustine
different things like that but of course
as we know Mark Waid actually ended up
leaving DC due to a fallout with Dan
DiDio and so the result was that he
effectively walked away from a lot of
the publication's that were going on at
the time but the popularity of Impulse
largely remain the same so what this
meant was that over the course of his
publication history with regards to the
impulse line of stories running between
1995 and 2002 there were a lot of
crossovers things like our worlds at war
and joker's last laugh and DC 1 million
different things like that not only that
the solo series of impulse while he did
crossover with the flash the solo series
focused largely on himself in addition
to max mercury and him basically
receiving all this tutoring and training
in terms of what it means to be a
superhero what his place is with regards
to the power he has how it relates to
the Speed Force seven things like that
the introduction of Thaddeus Thawne for
example one of the main villains of
impulse came out of his solo series
there were a lot of huge moments with
regards to his character that were for
the most part expanded however one of
the most notable roles that Bart Allen
played in the DC landscape was basically
being one of the three super heroes who
started Young Justice now of course
Young Justice originally launched back
in September I think it was in 1998 and
it ran for about five years running up
until November 2003 which actually
coincided with the relaunch of Teen
Titans but the funny thing about this
was that as far as I'm aware between
1996 and 1998 Dan Jergens was writing
the Teen Titans and the funny story
about this was that Dan Jurgis wanted to
bring Robin on to the Teen Titans in
order to bolster the popularity of the
team a problem with this was of the
batman editors said no and in truth i
have not been able to find any
information that actually tells us as to
why because of the fact that Robin
couldn't be used in Teen Titans in
dad Peter David Grabbe character
alongside Conner Kent men poles and
threw him in Young Justice now there was
a really cool interview that Peter David
did with to Mars publishing and one of
the things that he said was that when it
came to Young Justice
it was in a lot of ways testing the
waters for something outside of Teen
Titans and the reason for this was
because of the fact that the Teen Titans
had really kind of hit their stride
under the writing of Marv Wolfman and
they had never really achieved that
level of popularity until the relaunch
of Teen Titans going into the launch of
the TV show but up until that point
Marvin's run was a definitive run and if
they were going into the post zero-hour
crisis and time landscape while Teen
Titans wasn't necessarily the worst idea
the idea was to try something new to
basically experiment with something that
had been different from what had been
seen before now introducing impulse onto
Young Justice was huge because not only
did you have his own solo series you
also had characters like Connor Kent who
had basically just kind of been a
free-floating
entity ever since he stopped being the
metropolis kid during reign of the
Superman he was one of those characters
that DC never really knew what to do
with and so going into this five-year
run between 1998 running up until 2003
under the writing of Peter David we
ended up seeing you know this Young
Justice roster expand to a degree but
not become overly huge like Teen Titans
did and by the time it was all said and
done really the core characters are
Robins Superboy Wonder Girl and impulse
so with the exception of cassie
sandsmark I think it is or maybe Donna
Troy with the exception of like Wonder
Girl being introduced that was really
all there was I mean you had the
characters and yet crossovers but in
terms of the core roster it was kept
pretty minimal and it was kept pretty
small now again because of the fact that
Young Justice was so wildly popular you
know I'm on the reader base which
rightfully so if I were reading DC back
then I would have been all about Young
Justice but because of the fact of the
writing of Peter David kind of combined
with the nature of the characters really
set the stage for just this extremely
popular story DC was running into a
position where pardon my language it was
kind of like you know crap or get off
the pot they've long since been teasing
the idea that Bart Allen would replace
Wally West and so because of the fact
that Infinite Crisis was designed to
basically follow up to you know crisis
on Infinite Earths
as this kind of 20 year anniversary
issue as well as fix a lot of the
continuity issues that's still lingered
after crisis on Infinite Earths and had
been created after zero hour crisis in
time DC basically killed off the
character of Wally West they basically
removed him from the entirety of the DC
landscape and so what this did is it set
the stage for a story called the flash
fastest man alive which ran between 2006
and 2009 about five or six issues into
this according to an interview that was
done by Marc Guggenheim who is writing a
story at the time fans hated it while
they loved the character of Bart Allen
they loved the character of Wally West
even more and for the most part they've
been allowed to have their cake and eat
it too they've been allowed to have
Wally West as the flash and Bart Allen
his impulse both in his own solo series
at least up until it ended as well as in
the Young Justice line of stories and
because of the fact that Bart Allen's
line of comics dealt with things like
the disappearance of Max mercury and how
he was gonna live without his mentor
different things like that ultimately
fans just kind of felt betrayed a little
bit and so we're the fastest man alive
basically picked up in the aftermath of
Infinite Crisis which is to say Akhil
Bart Allen entering the Speed Force and
then coming out as an adult this ended
pretty fast and in fact in the same
interview that Marc Guggenheim had done
he had stated that according to DC
editorial as the mandate came down the
larger scope of how it is flash fastest
man alive
ended wasn't necessarily important what
was important was that Bart Allen had to
die he had to be killed off at the end
of the story and so art guggenheim
basically crafted the end of flash
fastest man alive
that essentially saw bart allen being
killed off by Thaddeus Thawne more or
less now of course this ran into the
beginning of Geoff Johns run on the
flash if not maybe a little bit before
and it ultimately resulted in Wally West
coming back his kids being aged up while
we learned that Bart Allen had been
killed by Thaddeus and they're just kind
of sitting Thaddeus in the stasis where
by time moved incredibly slow for him
you know like thousands of years have
passed so on and so forth now within DC
Comics the death of Bart Allen was
actually handled pretty tastefully you
know there were you know kind of like a
candlelight vigil different things like
that that went on but for the most part
a lot of the immediate aftermath focused
on Wally West and the fact that he felt
like he had failed the Kid Flash he had
his own you know protege for the most
part and his attempt to basically keep
you know Bart Allen safe had ultimately
failed when he had taken off with
regards to to the you know future of the
story and you know so on and so forth
and how he ended up playing his role and
so Bart Allen actually returned during
the events of Final Crisis legion of
three worlds I think it was and it was
really kind of like this shoehorned
explanation in the sense that it was
basically assume lightning rod or
something along those lines that had
basically given him his powers back but
it also brought back conner kent
Superboy who had also died now of course
this is the way for DC to grab a
character's role than
and in truth I would say a lot of this
was done because of the fact that if
making Bart Allen the flash was very
distasteful to fans and DC decided to
kill him off the best thing to do was to
grant a reprieve the flash sales aren't
doing as well as they used to we tried
to shift things up with Bart Allen fans
didn't like it so let's see if we can
just rework it in its entirety and so
Barry Allen coming back basically
retaking his mantle as the flash the
entire history of his character being
rewritten by Geoff Johns and flash
rebirth all these things going on
basically sort of cleared the air he was
essentially grabbing all these pieces
this huge muddled mess clearing it all
up and then throwing it all back out
there in a way that was more concise and
was more cohesive as though the result
was that Bart Allen was basically sent
back to his younger form and he became
Kid Flash once again now this saw him
running through a handful of stories but
the popularity he achieved in the
impulse line of stories between the
mid-1990s running all the way up into
the early 2000s and the end of Young
Justice he never really achieved that
level of popularity again this ran up
until about 2011 when DC rebooted with a
new 52 the problem with the rebooted
version of Bart Allen is a set of him
being called Bart Allen he was called
Bart tour and instead of him basically
being this young kid who was trying to
understand his place in the world that
relatability was replaced with the fact
that he was just basically some guy from
the future who was like a religious
fundamentalist fanatic or something like
that and so because DC had effectively
turned him into a religious zealot slash
terrorists fans hated it this was coming
off the heels of the fact that fans
didn't like the Teen Titans the way it
had been organized in the new 52
there was really no chance for Bart
Allen to survive with regards to his
character being popular and so over the
course of the whole teen titans run
really running up until like issues 25
and 26 when he was given a new origin as
well as the end of the teen titans
stories ultimately he was just kind of
sent back into the future and he was put
in jail for the crimes that he committed
and that was really about it now because
of the fact that DC rebirth is designed
for the purpose i was centrally trying
to wipe the slate clean quote-unquote
and to basically say not everything that
happened in the new 52 is still intact
that we're basically getting rid of the
things that you guys don't like and
we're keeping the things that you do
like the reboot never really took place
instead it was Manhattan just modifying
10 years out of everybody's mind what
this does is it sets the stage for DC to
basically say diversion to Bart Allen
that you saw in the new 52 that is that
doesn't exist just pretend like it never
happened and not many fans will complain
about that you know in fact the way it
seems to indicate
Allen is just still in the future we
don't really know what's going on with
this character we don't really know how
he fits in to the pre new 52 landscape
we don't know how those dots connect but
what we do know is that by virtue of
super suns of tomorrow the history still
seems to be intact and the character as
he's most fondly remembered by fans
still seems to be there it's just a
matter of finding a way to connect the
version that fans remember to the
versions that we've seen now but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
- comments explained to make sure you
guys have the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
hopefully this guy is this gives you
guys a pretty good understanding of Bart
Allen definitely interesting character I
mean yeah i would say aside from wally
west he's probably the most interesting
version of the flash shoes out there
just in terms of like the nature of his
personality different things like that i
mean a truth all the members of the
flash family brings something cool to
the table I always thought Jay Garrick
was probably the coolest version of the
flash old man flash he was always one of
my favorite versions but anyway guys
yeah so we're gonna go ahead and bring
this to an end and I will catch you all
later please
[Music]